ladies and gentleman for a very intimate
conversation please welcome to the stage
that one of the men behind life is
strange before the storm come on deck 9
thank you coming out thanks for having
me always now we've never met sir we we
actually might've met your throw me
under the bus right no it's fine okay
it's okay that you don't okay does your
mom that you don't remember when did we
meet uh past III I was a lead designer
on a on a game for Sony called warriors
lair for the Vita I think we might have
interviewed me very briefly what well
now did you forgive now this interviews
taking a completely different turn did
I'd like to talk about a warrior's lair
storm one person did what if this game
was gonna be Diablo on the Vita and was
gonna be moot we all had it was gonna be
amazing but because you guys didn't
support Vita enough it didn't happen I
hope you're all happy it's on you that
man has the bean I appreciate that a lot
no well what's your name introduce
yourself to everybody my name is Chris
Floyd I'm the co game director at deck 9
games and we're working on life is
strange before the storm man what any
three surprised I thought it was weird
when don't nods like we're putting up
this video we're not gonna be any three
work on a life - strange - then life is
strange a PlayStation Plus game I'm like
something's [ __ ] here but then this
and I didn't see it coming I have to say
you know working on the game for more
than a year and just knowing the fan
base that's out there for life is
strange sure you know keeping that
bottled up for so long that moment at
the Xbox conference when we finally had
our trailer up there Jeff letting
letting Chloe out of the bag as it were
fantastic moment for us okay so you you
I think hit the nail on the head for the
first part it's a game that's beloved
it's a game that has changed people's
lives there are so many cosplayers out
there how terrifying was it to actually
get this it is such it's it's a lot of
pressure for us you know what don't nod
created is spectacular and it's such a
unique vision yeah right so so to be
asked to come in and contribute to that
it's a lot of pressure but it's really
such a great privilege to be able to
work in this same universe and work with
characters and environments that they
created so you said a year a half you've
been cooking on it yeah over here
okay so how does this happen how do i
I'm unfamiliar with tec-9
what else have you worked on so deck 9
games is a set of veteran developers
we've been building a team actually for
the last three years and a set of tools
to make cinematic adventure games okay
so we brought in storytellers from film
and television as well as video games
made a great team of storytellers and we
made a tool set of tools we call story
force that really unleashes those people
and lets them bring their creative
vision into the game yeah and we just
had Square Enix come to us and start
talking to us about cinematic adventure
games next thing we know we're making
the next life is strange game we
couldn't believe it we wanted to play
the next game we didn't ha ha ha ha so I
mean I say it's all quite often I know
how to play video games and talk about
them but the business side of games I
never truly understand so you took a
meeting of square and they at some point
does it become obvious that they're
interviewing you I mean what they did
you know we actually talked to them
about some other possible games we might
make we showed them our technology
yeah this technology has been really
making some waves of everyone we show it
to let's make these kinds of games
veterans of eventual games they see if
they go oh we wish we could work with
these tools okay so that was the first
point that really I think caught their
attention and then honestly they put us
through the wringer
they made us uh recreate scenes from the
first life is strange they made us make
our own scene from our story and really
show that we could capture that unique
vision that the visual quality the
feeling of life is strange so then what
was the mandate from them or the order I
guess they put in is it like hey we want
you to make a life is strange game
that's before life is strange or do they
leave it up to you or well we knew that
fans wanted to return to Arcadia Bay and
there are a lot of fans who just wanted
to spend more time with characters that
they that they knew and that they loved
from the first game so other than that
Square was was gave us a lot of latitude
to give you a lot of different stories
Wow and where we landed was Chloe as our
protagonist and telling this story
that's really about that special person
that just comes into your life at the
right time
and just changes everything for you and
for Chloe
that's Rachel amber tell me about who
Rachel amber is I think you know being a
fan of life has changed
she was this character obviously she was
a motivating factor i but you know we
never got to know her and that she's
like a mythical figure in the fridge
right yeah everybody has something to
say about her they all have their own
interactions everybody loves her it's
still true in our game three years
before the original game she's the most
popular girls girl in school
she's super successful at at school at
everything she does she's kind of
everything to everyone
yeah Chloe on the other hand totally
different she's an outcast her father
just died two years before in a tragic
accident
her best friend max taken off lost touch
she's really alone against the whole
world
so when Rachel shows up it's really
going to be a transformative moment and
these two kind of oil and water are
going to come together and they're going
to find that they both need each other
to lean on during this period of our
story
so when concept art leaked and we're all
like started getting real oils going on
here I started crafting a story of like
how would this work how would they do
this and I'm like it'll be we plays
Rachel amber she has the rewind power
but she understands she has to die and
to make you know bah bah and then you
guys just flat-out came out like no
you're playing as Chloe there's no
rewind that's right we absolutely like
it say we considered a lot of different
options and playing Rachel was totally
one of them yeah one of the neat things
is that when rachel is the person you
have a relationship with the way you did
with Chloe in the first game that's the
character you kind of really actually
get to explore it's kind of a paradox
there of exploring who she is at least
through the lens of Chloe and seeing
Rachel through Chloe's eyes given what
she said about Rachel that was really
really really appealing to us sure so
yeah I mean there's so many other things
about Chloe that also we're really
interesting partly how different she is
from max right sure she's a little spiky
she's got a lot of attitude Max is very
timid and cautious and that just really
appealed to us too we think it brings a
whole new tone to the game so I
understand the story forage you're
talking about how great the Macan of the
tools are what makes them special what
makes them stand out
well it really has it really has two
parts it starts in a tool we call play
right and that's like let's basically
like writing a screenplay our writers
can write a screenplay yeah except they
can also add in all those branches and
consequences and all those those moments
that make the game play what it is they
build that straight into into that
screenplay then we suck that over into a
game new to us a tool we call
storyteller where we start to build our
cinematic sequences that's like a giant
timeline you bring in a character you
give it animations you get in there in
the the facial the facial expressions we
literally have sliders that you can grab
and turn up the sadness and turn down
the surprise or mix them however you
want to it's just a face to see my face
slider you go somewhere between it
literally that's what we do yeah Wow
okay that's interesting were you worried
about fan reaction to first off a
prequel but secondly hey there are no
rewind powers this is just going to be
how Chloe interacts with all these
different people sure we knew we were
making some bold decisions yeah but we
also one felt that ultimately the real
beating heart of life is strange
are these relatable characters these
realistic relationships and the
real-world issues that they deal with in
their life now of course we're going to
have you know life is still strange sure
we're going to have some strange and
supernatural elements in there but the
power in particular to address that it
just really didn't make sense for one
thing max is a character that that timid
cautious character the the the rewind
power really was an expression of who
she was and what what her sort of issues
that she needed to deal with were as
opposed to Chloe
that's that's not that's not her so we
felt like breaking out of that a little
bit was really what was appropriate for
Chloe's story of course and so then
what's don't knobs involvement like our
did you you get the job from square are
you talking them at the same time are
they approving what you're doing so
don't not is very very busy as they
announced a few weeks ago yeah working
on their own follow up to life is
strange and like everybody else we're
really excited to see what that's going
to be we've been very very busy working
on the first episode of
or the storm but we did get
opportunities to share what we were
working on with don't nod we've
collected some of their feedback our
head writer took our first episode out
to them sat down and played the game
with them back it up a bunch of really
fantastic feedback and that's really
informed how we've have we've gone along
and and tried to stay true to the
original I haven't been so nightmarish
I'm sitting there just wincing every
time anybody said or did anything just
like I don't they set the bar colossal
'high right and and there's no doubt
about that
so we're just we're just really proud to
have the opportunity to live up to that
so why three episodes three episodes you
know we could have gone with more we
maybe could have gone with less I really
like it you know in these days of
digital television you know with Netflix
you now have creators to really get to
define they don't need to hit those
forty-seven minutes or whatever with
commercial breaks anymore they get to
define how long you know their TV show
should be same with us we had the option
to we just had to look at our story and
say what did we need to tell this story
and three episodes felt just right and
then I thought it was interesting you
guys came out you talked about the three
episodes but then you talked about in
the deluxe edition write this farewell
episode you want to talk about that yeah
that's right we knew of course the fans
wanted to return to Arcadia Bay we also
felt like a lot of fans would want to
play max just one more time
yeah so we decided to add a bonus
episode the three Episode before the
storm is self-contained this bonus
episode goes a little further back with
young max and lets you play max for just
one more farewell episode I'm assuming
it's when she leaves am I correct is it
a farewell dark a tea bag we're now
ready to talk about that night after the
death am i right are we saying farewell
the dad that could be the other thing is
it close father I I plead the fifth yeah
you know though you know so how are you
guys doing episodic content because was
always interesting with episodic is the
fact like telltale is able to change and
adjust do you guys feel like you're
three episodes are locked and you know
exactly what's happening or is it
episode one's going to come out and
there's time to take what people say and
change we constructed an arc of the
whole storyline very early on yeah but
of course as you get in and you really
work with these characters and you
with individual scenes and you start to
see what's working and what's not it's
absolutely true that things change so
well we started with a lot of attention
on our first episode and we and we move
on to each episode we know basically
what the main points are but things
change and we even may have some
opportunities to react to what the fancy
in Episode one and and touch up some
moments in Episode two and three if
we're lucky when I'm requesting in
Episode three is the final thing I do is
dye my hair blue just putting it out
there duly noted
it's one that there would you like to
dye your hair blue there we go there we
go because then it's you know it's we're
setting it up for the next one now
you're definitely going to see that
transformation in many ways in terms of
her personality at least of Chloe
turning into that character that you
know from the off season I guess then my
next question would be how did you at
what point do you go back and play life
is strange again is it that you sit
there and go you wrote you've obviously
played the first time cuz it's amazing
you get the job you play it again you
write your script in you're playing it
while you do that then after you finish
your script and you go back to plate and
see how it would actually add it like
how many times you play - strange we
look at the game all the time as you say
when we started the project of course we
went over with a fine-tooth comb we
looked at it in some cases literally
frame by frame to see how you create you
know the visuals and the cinematic
moments from the game to really break it
down and understand it we returned to it
all the time because it's so important
for us to hit it just right where the
thing about the episodic narrative
adventure right is that so many people
like to hate on it it's not a game I'm
just watching a movie or why do you love
it I love I love these opportunities to
take these characters in some really
radical directions you know life is
strange dealt with some some really
heavy stuff right and and and made you
make some choices that you really felt
and you knew the consequences you knew
there were coming at some point and then
we're going to hit you and especially
now for our game with no rewind power
you can't take these back we're doubling
down on those consequences
Chloe has to live with them the player
has to live with them you're gonna feel
them in your gut life is strange before
this
episode 1 comes out August 31st that's
right for Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC
on Steam and then it'll end with me dye
my hair blue and the farewell thing is
me leaving right we will see God
everybody round of applause or like
exchange that's my game thanks